people were really upset and men were
really upset at what
like it's literally the closest thing
i've ever heard of audio pornography
you must not have heard a lot of men rap
it's aimed at
young american girls can you even
imagine what it's doing to them
i don't cook i don't clean
wet ass p word people are like this is
vulgar
inappropriate what about the children
that look up to them
do women achieve equality by aspiring to
and replicating the values that have
been established by males we tried our
best to enjoy it but it's been a lot of
politics
there's a lot of female rappers that be
wrapping their ass
off and don't be talking about they
don't blame that
on us when you're not the one that's
supporting them
[Music]
my name is brandi blaise i primarily do
a lot of trap music
rooted in feminism which is really
important for me as
a fat black queer woman
i'm uh joey natto i gained most of my
following from youtube
i make positive motivational music
i can see through the lines no i don't
get the picture
my name is i'm black muslim and i care
about activism
my name
[Music]
i am an mc and hip-hop cultural
ambassador for the united states
i am queen herbie
[Music]
the messages in my music are definitely
centered around self-care
and building confidence and knowing your
worth what's the point of seeing caesar
if you lose such a jesus then i pledge
my allegiance
my name is ruslan i'm a christian and
the vision for what i do is to encourage
empower inspire people to
live god's dream for their life so much
trip you would thought that i leave this
school with it my name is samaya savage
i represent weird kids like myself
who didn't necessarily fit into school
and stuff
[Music]
and the first prompt is rap should only
send
uplifting and meaningful messages brandy
i'm going to disagree joey i think i'll
say strongly disagree
neelam i actually disagree too pinky
strongly disagree queen i disagree
ruslan agree samad
strongly disagree as as a father as
someone who has kids or someone who has
little nieces and
sees the consequences of
there not being enough uplifting and
meaningful music
i think it should i think there should
be substantially more
i don't think that lyrics have to be
uplifting and meaningful i feel like you
know like the police
that wasn't uplifting to some but it was
uplifting to others
it shouldn't only be and always be
because ain't [ __ ] sweet all the time
right
particularly in communities of color
it's not right and we need to talk about
that we need to report on that
i've heard someone like in being a
rapper as a the weatherman or whether
woman
where you just tell it how it is outside
i think
that we put undue pressure
on rappers to be role models for young
people
we're never really telling these rock
stars who are out here doing coke and
like
having sex with all these women that
they need to be a role model for their
community so why are we always putting
this heavy heavy pressure on rappers and
i said strongly disagree
but that like really like stuck out to
me a lot because
i hate when female artists are like
over sexualizing themselves and i think
my same reaction happened with
nicki minaj and cardi b i was like
they're doing too much like over
sexualizing themselves like i do not
like them now
but you know that they're not there to
you know be all rainbows and butterflies
so i think that was just
a great point and it really you know
shifts my perspective
my thing is when the the culture as a
whole
starts shifting and going darker and
darker and darker and this is what i
mean
can we all agree that illicit drug use
is bad
popping pills heart we're not talking
about smoking week we can we all just
say
yeah no good drugs bad right
well you have one of the biggest pop
stars who's a who's a grown man in his
mid-30s and a father
and the chorus of his song is him about
talking about popping pills i took a
half she took the whole thing
and we we we take that and it just goes
over our heads and we're just so numb to
it we're so desensitized to it
look drake is not my son's role model he
will never be my son's role model i'm my
son's role model i'm the father
but let's be honest there are kids there
a lot of them black and brown kids from
poor areas where single parents
are prevalent single parent homes are
prevalent you think that these
these these icons don't have massive
influence on them
so you guys are right yeah i don't
expect drake to be a role model
but i expect the 34 year old dad
to be mindful of who's listening i have
been listening to
eminem and i mean old school m m who did
not give a damn
about anything saying whatever he wanted
since i was a baby
as i was born i don't know if it was
playing in a hospital room as i was
coming out
like that's all i've been listening to
and i'm still who i am today
and the reason being is because my mom
has always allowed me to watch and
listen to these things and has always
pulled me to the side and said
eminem can rap about killing people and
popping pills but that's not real life
that's not what you gonna do
you were really blessed your mom is a
real one yeah thank god you know
my mom at the same time that she told me
these things every once in a while
my father wasn't around so she was in
and out the house
working and and going to college she
wasn't really around like that either
uh i did get into some some things that
i wasn't supposed to get into
i had older cousins older siblings who
were affiliated with gangs
uh family members who were drug dealers
and stuff like that like i may have grew
up in a decent neighborhood
but every single person in my family was
not in the neighborhood that i was in
growing up i had a really incredible
single mom but my mom didn't censor any
music i listened to
i ended up listening to a lot of missy
elliott a lot of little kim little kim
is my icon
so i grew up with a lot of those
messages and i think sometimes people
just boil it down to
oh my god they're influencing kids that
have sex and this is bad
one of the messages that i got out of
listening to little kim
into missy elliott that i kept with me
as an adult and i still keep with me
is things that they don't teach you when
sex ed
or your parents probably not going to
teach you when they teach you about the
birds and the bees like
one thing that i learned from media that
i wasn't protected from
was that you have just as much ownership
as in sex
that you are just old just as much
pleasure and
they're supposed to deliver it to you
that really kept me from having sex
because i was like
these little rusty boys was coming
around talking about yeah you know
come to my house after school you know
um what's up
and i was like oh no cause kim said um
i'm happy with the state of our industry
today
brandy disagree joey i must say somewhat
agree
nilam i strongly disagree pinky i
somewhat disagree queen i disagree
ruslan i strongly disagree some odd
disagree
i teach a hip-hop program and an
entrepreneurship program to my students
and i'm still having to tell them you
need to have another hustle
right i want people to be able to
function within the music industry and
make enough money
i'm not 100 an artist yet and that's
really frustrating
i think if we approached this entire
thing as small business owners and we
said hey
i know that the first year of the
business the second year the third year
listen i'm just trying to survive but i
mean tick tock right now it could happen
within
a week or two where you can legitimately
build a new audience on tick tock that
you could transition over
even though you built this whole thing
yourself and got to a point where it's
like actually making money which
nowadays like you have to be huge on
tick tock or they have to see
opportunity
to get to pull that money out of you
right away
two percent of those artists actually
recoup which means
only two percent get to make a second
album once you get in the machine it's
like
your chances of surviving it are very
slim i'm biased because i wouldn't have
been able to flourish
in a different time in the music
industry because my come up was on
um primarily from youtube i live in
boston and i'm from boston
if you just google the press coverage on
boston hip-hop you'll primarily see
women
and you'll primarily see non-buying
artists and that's really something that
i hope can be replicated within
the bigger industry like i think we're
making strides towards that
we also have um supportive foundations i
received like a five-figure grant
to completely fund my third album and
before that i've been 100
self-funded i still have a day job y'all
okay i was at work this morning
there's a specific kind of men that run
this that aren't black men that are
putting out these negative stereotypes
no offense to
[Music]
if anybody talking about the negative
portrayal of any race and whatnot we
have to talk about who owns these labels
who's funding these labels and funding
the industry and that's what made me say
i don't really care if i'm in the
industry or not as long as i'm getting
my back to support my family i'm good
so that's why i strongly disagree
because
the music industry to me is it's a joke
and it's
agenda the song [ __ ] is a feminist anthem
strongly agree i feel like i'm going to
be shifted but for right now i'll just
say disagree
strongly disagree i somewhat agree i
agree
strongly disagree with the caveat that i
i actually have never heard the song
somewhat agree as a woman
if you're going to reduce me down to a
whop it's a part of me
but for that to be the anthem of this is
what just
brings us liberation as women that's a
literal joke to me
and it also is kind of offensive because
you're downplaying me to a physical
thing and i am
a being that is just way too much for
you period it's females that made that
song
as far as i know i don't know if anybody
else wrote it because it's the music
industry
well what's interesting about that is
actually there are
there are male writers in that song
which is very funny because we call that
our liberation but men are telling us
i want to gag i want to choke is this
song the only
anthem for feminism no not at all
there are songs that go way beyond and
talk about the actual
powers that women have beyond physical
appearance and
physical parts um but i know that some
women
find empowerment in their sexuality
and if it brings power to those women
that listen to it
then it's supporting feminism i
definitely 100
agree with that like i love law i did a
remix to walk i love that song i don't
care
but i'm i know the only person that said
strongly agree because it is about
ownership of body
and ownership of sexuality sometimes i
feel like
when you are a rapper that does that
either people assume that it was put on
to you by men
which it wasn't or they assume that you
can't do anything else
or you're not as smart or you're not as
good and for me
personally sex being such a predominant
theme of my music
is very personal for me for two reasons
one
being a plus-sized black woman the only
representation i've seen in myself
in media is the sassy asexual best
friend
that's never the love interest that's
never viewed in a sexual way
my music and why it's it's just kind of
like
me exploring my sexuality and having
that ownership i'm also a rape survivor
and one way that i learned to cope with
that was ownership of my sexuality
and ownership of my body because i was
taken away from me
and obviously that's not the way that a
lot of people are gonna cope
but for me that was how i coped and i
got through that trauma
that's as intense as getting those
things ripped away from you
is that it's mine now and i have a
hundred percent ownership of it
and how i choose to display it is a
hundred percent
on me and i feel a lot of power and a
lot of liberation from that
and i think it's okay if you don't um
but i don't think you should discount
women that do
in fact some facts
um i just wanted to say so i somewhat
agreed
um because there are other songs that i
would say
are probably better feminist anthems
right but when we think about what
feminism is
period it's just believing the equality
of both genders right
so if we can have dudes talking about
their dicks and [ __ ] and
sucking and all of this stuff then
like people were really upset and men
were really upset at what they were
honey they were mad mad mad mad mad
why can't i show my young girls that
owning their sexuality is powerful then
right like i wish someone told me that
and
um i brandi thank you so much for
sharing that because i share the same
experience
why can't we have
someone telling us that so that we know
to own it before someone else is taking
that from us
for me the wap song is another i also
covered it
for me it was like a huge liberating
moment and this is coming from an artist
that has a song called
bde which stands for big dick energy
because this whole time i've been trying
to
liberate myself sexually and like be
comfortable with who i am and what my
desires are as a woman i thought i
needed to put on
a fake dick you know and write a song
about like that my energy has a big dick
it was just so liberating for me to hear
women and by the way shout out to mega
stallion who is a prolific
freestyler i'm pretty sure she probably
wrote her bars
i just wanted to add that my little lens
of perspective from a little
nebraska girl for the first time it
feels like in a long time it's
she's talking about what she wants to do
and what she likes instead of talking
about what
a man likes and what a man wants and
stuff like that and that's why i feel
like the power comes from in the song i
also think that men were upset because
of the sample
so the original song that has there's
some holes in that house
that's great it's a classic everybody
loves it but a woman took it and flipped
it
and now it's not about degradation
anymore it's about liberation
then now it's a problem as expected this
conversation did
really shift my view on why i've only
heard it once
because once was enough for me because
it didn't make me mad but it was just
too much like it's literally the closest
thing i've ever heard of audio
pornography
you know i was bouncing to it and
everything like everybody's float like i
could
appreciate the artisticness behind it
you must not have heard a lot of men rap
because that's
yeah no i guess maybe because it's the
shock value and i'm wondering
what do you think the intent was behind
the song do you think it was
to like empower women or do you think it
was to shock people
and get views and clicks just from the
shock factor usually
a lot worse comes from men so i was like
y'all are y'all are scandalized by this
i 100 agree with you brandy it was like
oh my god it's like first of all too
it's consistent with what cardi do why
are you guys so like oh my god like you
haven't heard her
that's party cardio is being cardi this
notion that men were upset
like i wasn't upset i saw the promo for
it and i was just kind of like
i've seen this story before this is
little kim pass for me
in this being an anthem for feminism
uh what what other modern songs are
better representations
what are modern feminist anthems that
don't degrade women
i believe it was rolling stone like
declared
rhapsody's last album eve as like a
maybe a masterpiece and hip-hop feminism
or something like that
the fact that you know some people don't
know that about her or don't know that
about her album or having listened to
her album
means that as women we're losing the
fact that [ __ ] comes out and now we're
celebrating our sexuality
and men are up in arms and upset about
it but don't you know check their own
when it comes to that we're losing as
long as we continue to function within a
patriarchal society
and a genre of music that is inherently
misogynistic
we're losing i have felt discriminated
against in my industry
i strongly agree somewhat agree i agree
strongly agree
somewhat agree somewhat agree i agree
i've had a lot of doors shut just based
on the way that i look
no one even cared if i could rap it was
automatically you're a woman and then if
people could get over that
they couldn't get over my size and being
a plus-sized woman
that raps a lot about a lot of sexual
things i
got a lot of no's just based on that
like no one wants to hear that
from a woman that looks like you so not
necessarily that they don't want to hear
it from a woman at all
it was very much a woman that looks like
you but i also get a lot of love from
people that are like
you look like me you look like my family
you look like like my friends
and we all wanna you know pablo some
song
so we wanna hear it randy i'm just
living for you
i just love you so much
[Laughter]
we know that representation matters
right we see it all the time and yet
for some reason when it comes to bigger
women
it's just no but not that kind of
representation
but there are women out there that want
to hear that that want to feel empowered
in their bodies
um in their sexuality so my friends are
rapper rappers right and so they
are constantly like pink i don't
understand what the problem is and i'm
like
it's because i have a vagina that's
really all it is
it's gender i think in like hip-hop
especially is the most common
discrimination there's a prototype
of a female rapper and if you don't fit
it naturally you're getting
discriminated against
i'm kind of like a faux pas in this
industry because it's like
not only are you not hyper sexualized
you're freaking muslim so it's like dude
you don't even fit in this
category you know what i'm saying it's
back in the day i used to be able to
listen to little kim
and lauren hill on the radio both you
know and
i just feel like there's just a need of
balance
yeah and even when you do have your
cardi and you have someone like a
rhapsody
why isn't she getting as much funding or
as much air time and as much play
because
she is you know the opposite she is
something that we need and want so um i
teach
hip-hop to mostly young women and a lot
of them didn't even know who she was
didn't know a lot of these sort of
underground women mcs
that are doing really dope stuff and
it's like why aren't we putting money
towards that
i have to still put myself in agree
because of the content that i choose to
rap about
i rap about real things that are going
on in the world i rap about how there's
more than 75 000
black women missing in the world i rap
about the
thing that's going on in china israel
and palestine i write about all of that
stuff
so a lot of people are afraid to get on
tracks with me because they think that
i might get blackballed and that might
get them blackballed
so it's by choice i love this
discrimination wow i'm so happy that i'm
a part of this conversation you guys
already pointed out so many lenses that
i don't even see
and i think definitely as a white woman
making black music
i think it's important to acknowledge
that first
do you feel like you've been
discriminated against for being a white
woman in rep
the first deal that i signed was with la
reid and one of the first things he said
after the ink was dry was like
we're not gonna wrap like you are you're
gonna fit into this like katy perry box
much better like if you want to get the
bag
this is what you do and you know when la
reid tells you that that's what you
you listen for the longest time i had to
sort of unpack what that meant
and what my lesson was leading me to and
i had to be honest a lot of work to do
in terms of learning the art form of rap
just personally a motto that i do my
best to live by is i
i go where i'm celebrated and not just
tolerated
like i'm a i'm an immigrant refugee
english is not my first language but i'm
viewed white by society so i have a
degree of white privilege i'm a white
guy in hip-hop
who's an independent artist who's a
christian so this is like
all those different things there's a
degree of
discrimination that i faced because of
all that but i would say
it the privilege that i've had of being
viewed as a white male in society has
far
outweighed the any consequences or any
negative sides of
you know being the minority in a
predominantly black art form
music can lead to real-life violence
against women
disagree uh i agree i agree wrongly
agree
uh somewhat disagree i agree some would
agree
if i'm saying every day
slap trick and i'm listening to that
over and over again
as a woman to constantly hear that and
as a man or a young boy
to constantly hear that's how you talk
to talk about a woman
and then your perception that you have a
woman and you you see a girl and you're
like look at that [ __ ]
oh it's only because i hear that over
and over again she's she's a whole she's
a [ __ ] the
you know what i'm saying and then even
changes how i treat her now i treat her
like she just nothing you know what i'm
saying because i constantly have that in
my ear i just think it would be foolish
to think that incantations ain't real
and that those songs have that type of
power when we think about violence like
it doesn't have to mean physical
violence all the time
right um i feel personally traumatized
sometimes when i hear some
some music or certain things that are
said i think it was rick ross that had
like a line that was about like
you know raping a woman or you know what
i mean that traumatized me so when we
think about violence like we have to
understand that it's not just actual
physical harm that's happening it could
be mental emotional she made me like
kind of
think of kind of like that spiritual or
like emotional violence which i really
didn't think of
so i'm not gonna say i change or
disagree i'm gonna say somewhat disagree
because i still do
um just that violence against women
violence in general is beginning of time
a lot of the biggest influences are
right in our neighborhoods right on our
block
you know what i mean like if i know my
father got killed on the block
then yeah i'm much more likely to have a
gun and much more likely to probably go
kill somebody else
i don't think that has anything to do
with gangster rap i agree with you i
feel like
it you can't blame violence on music but
i
like i'm like in south central and stuff
like that i
i just know like as far as the
suggestion it's
a suggestion just in the psyche
a lot of this stuff is theme music i've
been on rides where people were
i this ain't really snitching on myself
i've been on rides where people were
like
had evil intent and whatnot and they
were on their way to go do some
evil stuff and what were they playing
what were the theme songs you you
guessed it
some gangsta rap so
can it influence and encourage yes
but it's not the blame i'm i i listen to
shoot em up rap music whenever i listen
to that while i'm
cleaning the dishes in my suburban home
and it doesn't make me say you know what
let me stop doing these dishes and go
run outside and kill somebody real quick
i just want to say i'm grateful for all
these perspectives because i chose
somewhat disagree
because i don't want it to be true i
don't want to think that music can
influence violence in that way so i just
grateful because i am re-examining how
my brain
actually processes that i'm thinking
about the next generation i'm thinking
about my nieces i'm thinking about my
nephews that aren't
there yet where they don't understand
yeah i consume this song for escapism
and i consume this song to be in touch
with my inner freak
i i think there's a balance there but i
definitely think that if you're not in
the right
frame of mind you can definitely be
triggered to go do some wild stuff
buy a song or the song is just playing
and if you're mentally weak
then you're gonna be influenced you're
eat you're more prone to be influenced
by music to do you know carry out
violence and stuff like that
but also remember drive-bys did
definitely happen in the 70s when
everybody was listening to funk music
so anything can happen to anything i'm
gonna be thinking about a lot of things
i feel like i'm just gonna be looking at
a wall thinking about life for the next
three hours
after this whole conversation and you
guys were all
really fun to talk to and listen to you
can learn something from everyone and i
really loved it
and i wish the industry could be as
diverse as
this i'm all y'alls man now that's just
it that's all i have to say
period died let's give women mcs their
flowers
now please right let's support them
let's uplift them
because how are we going to get to the
next phase unless like we all said
we are the ones we have to support like
the more we're gonna start seeing
this resurgence of other young women who
come up and are able to do it
because we're paving the way for them
hey guys thanks so much for checking out
this episode of spectrum
the music we consume directly influences
how we participate in a culture
that accepts the oppression and violence
against women and girls
spotlight initiative and the social good
club have teamed up on a mission
to help all types of content creators
across the world to use their platforms
to help shape a culture without male
dominance
to create safe spaces for everyone to
live in peace and thrive
they have rolled out a playbook to
kickstart this journey so make sure to
check it out at socialgoodclub.com
be sure to follow them at spotlight
initiative and at the social good club
and check out the hashtag with her
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time